Bayeux, with a pleasant town center and only six miles from the D-Day beaches,...
...makes a great home base for visiting the area's sites.
Along the 75 miles of Atlantic coast nearby,...
...you'll find countless memories of the largest military operation in history.
It was on these beautiful beaches at the crack of dawn, June 6, 1944,...
...that the Allies finally gained the foothold in France...
...and Nazi Europe began to crumble.
During the D-Day invasion, American troops and their Allied partners...
...courageously assaulted the German-occupied cliffs using grappling hooks and ladders.
While ultimately victorious, they suffered horrendous losses.
Smashed German bunkers and bomb craters remain,...
...only hinting at the unimaginable carnage and chaos of that momentous day.
The small town of Arromanches was ground zero for the D-Day invasion.
Almost overnight, the Allies erected an immense prefab port,...
...enabling them to begin their victorious push to Berlin.
Imagine the building of this incredible harbor.
Seventeen old ships steamed across the English Channel and were sunk bow to stern,...
...creating a four-mile-long protective breakwater.
Then, with massive concrete platforms and roads floating on pontoons nearly a mile long,...
...the harbor was completed.
Within six days, 300,000 Allied troops and all their equipment...
...had established a beachhead here in France.
And less than a year later, the war was over.
Today, 60 years later, the town, with its beachcombers,...
...holiday trinkets and families at play,...
...still seems to celebrate that Allied victory.